each of the nominees for Best Actress in
a supporting role is proven and powerful
they are four women plus in accordance
with California state law Meryl Streep
thank you I was a little nervous about
that one they've reached amassed a
stellar body of work and it's my honor
to tell you their names here are the
nominees for performance by an actress
and a supporting role Patricia Arquette
boyhood laura dern wild Keira Knightley
the imitation game
Emma Stone Birdman or the unexpected
virtue of ignorance meryl streep
into the woods
and the Oscar goes to Patricia Arquette
boy
okay thank you to the Academy to my
beautiful powerful nominees to IFC
Jonathan sarin John sloth kathleen
sutherland molly man david DiCamillo our
whole cast and our crew my boyhood
family who i love and admire our
brilliant director Richard Linklater the
impeccable Ethan Hawke my lovelies Ellar
Coltrane
Lorelai Linkletter Thomas and Paul thank
you for giving me my beautiful children
Enzo and Harlow you're the deepest
people that I know my friends who all
work so hard to make this world a better
place to my parents Rosanna Richmond
Alexis and David to my favorite painter
in the world Eric white for the
inspiration of living with the genius -
my heroes volunteers and experts who
have helped me bring ecological
sanitation to the developing world with
give love dorg
to every women who gave birth to every
taxpayer and citizen of this nation we
have fought for everybody else's equal
rights it's our time to have wage
equality once and for all and equal
rights for women in the United States of
America
you